during hurricane Harvey 27 inches of
water flooded the Bergin's home in this
trash pile represents all that's left of
their belongings this isn't the first
time their home is flooded but it may be
the last time that they rebuild it's not
just bricks and wood it's it's our home
Rachel Burgin her husband David and
their two teenagers live in a house
that's been in bergen's family for 52
years it just looks like six inches of
flood water from tropical storm Allison
crept into the house in 2001 but last
month during hurricane Harvey more than
two feet of water inundated the home the
Bergin's like the overwhelming majority
of other households in the area didn't
have flood insurance would you consider
getting flood insurance afterwards now
yes with Allison it was six inches this
is much more devastated
this is wall this is furniture thank
goodness stuff can be replaced FEMA says
it's still assessing flood damage from
hurricanes
Irma and Harvey as of Saturday more than
100,000 claims have been submitted under
FEMA's National Flood Insurance Program
which is nearly 25 billion dollars in
debt they estimate the cost to the
program for Harvey alone will reach 11
billion dollars following superstorm
sandy in 2012
FEMA paid over eight point six billion
dollars in flood insurance claims
according to a recent report the
National Flood Insurance Program spent
five point five billion dollars between
1978 and 2015 and repaired more than
30,000 properties that repeatedly
flooded take a hard look at the toll on
your family and your finances former
FEMA administrator Craig Fugate
ultimately for the taxpayer there's a
point at which when we deal with
repetitive loss it doesn't make sense to
keep paying for those properties over
and over again unless we're changing
something either mitigating or elevating
that home or offering buyouts what do
you do if it floods again
I think my husband has had third strike
get more out as much as we love this and
we need to rebuild and want to rebuild
it we're both public school teachers and
so there the cost comes in Houston area
officials are hoping the federal
government will buy back some homes in
those flood prone areas and according to
the Houston Chronicle they've already
received requests from about 1,000
homeowners that are looking to sell gale
Wow tough decisions to make there thank
you very much Omar